qu'aujourd'hui mercredi 14 décembre 2022
nous sortons dans nos belles salles du
ciné 7 à Élancourt
le volet numéro 2 du 13 attendu avatar
12 ans 11 ans je sais plus exactement
après le premier épisode donc avatar la
voix de l'eau réalisée par le fameux
James Cameron qu'on entend partout dans
les médias aujourd'hui
3h12 de films évidemment un film qui a
été réalisé en vrai 3D ça c'est
important de le dire parce que on a été
obligé de cavaler un petit peu pour
remettre à niveau tout notre équipement
3D que nous n'avions pas utilisé depuis
des lustres période de covid en plus en
plus voilà donc tout ça fonctionne très
bien je rassure les spectateurs et donc
Cameron moi je lui rend hommage parce
que c'était quand même un grand monsieur
du cinéma qui travaille énormément qui
adore les nouvelles technologies qui
alors l'eau vous le savez
très beau à bis qui a réalisé il y a
très longtemps maintenant et donc il
insiste beaucoup et ça c'est très
appréciable pour nous exploitants pour
que son film sorte exclusivement en
sortie mondiale dans les cinémas voilà
et j'insiste là-dessus et pas sur les
plateformes dans toutes les interviews
qu'il fait ils redit l'importance de la
salle de cinéma de ce lieu magique où
nous partageons ensemble des émotions le
film n'est pas est-il très réussi je ne
l'ai pas encore vu mais il paraît qu'on
ne voit pas passer les trois heures 12
de films donc nous le projetons aussi
les 7 pendant 4 semaines au moins en 3D
et en 2D en VF dans un premier temps
parce que c'est les ce sont les
exigences du distributeur mais on
récupérera de la VO à partir de la
troisième semaine et nous vous attendons
donc très nombreux pour découvrir avec
nous ce très beau film très
spectaculaire avatar la voix de l'eau